[Music]
Fox News has now confirmed that an 11th
person has died in the Dominican
Republic
this comes as Dominican health officials
lash out at recent reports exposing the
deaths of nearly a dozen American
tourists while visiting their country
officials calling it quote fake news and
hysteria aimed at hurting the country's
tourism meanwhile the FBI is reportedly
analyzing alcohol samples from at least
one hotel minibar from a popular resort
in the country to see if tainted booze
is to blame for string of tourist deaths
okay so you guys government officials
are using the hashtag be fair to gr to
combat this what they what they call if
I just said hysteria
you can argue however one life is one
life too many and tourism makes up 17%
of their economy it's not like it's 99
so how do we respond to that I the dr
needs a dr look i I don't think
Dominican Republic wants they shouldn't
be the mayor from Jaws you know you want
to be Roy Scheider so it's like it's
like you don't want to diminish a
problem you want to solve the problem
and the media I think can help by
shining a spotlight but they can hurt
because in the early stages of all this
nobody knows what's going on
so I sympathize with the Dominican
Republic in that it's not all hysteria
as the lower third says but there is
some hysteria that can confine this fog
of war can make everybody's rearranging
the words to different equations without
actually getting at the truth and I
think the five should go and do our
location show at the dr lift the boycott
yep georgette you've got to lift the
boycott if it's all expenses paid I'm in
yeah but don't what every bar what a
principled boycott my goodness I got an
ear infection the last time I was there
from swimming no that's it yeah but I
sympathize with them because a lot of
stuff isn't true but there is something
there that we have to solve it's they're
part of it is they're irresponsible yeah
exactly I don't think they have been
transparent I don't think they've been
clear with people about what's going
so then you know it's like people then
fill the void with rumors and
supposition we all agree we've said on
this show you know it's a small
percentage of the total number of
visitors that the Dominican Republic so
I don't think we've been unfair but I do
say and I'm not speaking for you but I
do think it's to me like for example on
this David Ortiz shooting thing now you
now say oh it wasn't David Ortiz it was
a target I think you guys covering
something up here I don't feel right to
me so but it's to me it's like Malaysia
and the missing plane the answers with
the Malaysian government right I think
again the Dominican government should
not be to use your analogy should be
more Roy Scheider or not the mayor
exactly well I find it very distasteful
that they're using the phrase like fake
news you know just because you don't
agree with something that doesn't mean
it's fake where did they get that
responsible of them so as I've been
saying I believe this is a Caribbean
inside job this is tourism terrorism
sabotage some would say I looked up the
numbers and what did I find the dr
brings in about six point one eight
million international tourists year the
number one caribbean tourist destination
in the caribbean close second cuba and
then fourth puerto rico so main suspects
we know the agency in the dr actually
said this this was a terrorism attack
okay all right the PR puerto rico was
just hit by a devastating storm they're
losing out on a lot of tourism dollars
suspect number one suspect number two we
have cuba now as you know obama opened
up that island then trump came in and
closed it so that window has shrunk
their thank you Obama for dollars there
those are my two main suspects Obama
keep this investigation open Obama oh my
god also very alarming are you serious
one people are done in the library
Colonel Mustard and we get hyper
whatever clearly with the mini bottle of
scotch
yeah just wait so this place right yes I
would be interested in who the PR firm
is that they hired about their American
and that would be fine right
I'm good this is American jobs we're
talking about the other thing is not
only is a government not just take a
little semblance of we'll check it out
we'll check it out we don't think
there's a thing but we'll check it but
instead it's just like and you had with
that one billionaire from down there
saying it's actually Americans who
cannot handle alcohol or law you can eat
buffets right there is a total of
response besides staunch denial and be
fair needy are and absolutely not and
we'll check into it and we're sorry for
your loss
you're a lawyer what do the families get
I mean what what what rights they have
what can they do with this government
like like if who's my face if my
relative died there what can I do well
it depends first of all they need the
information that the government hasn't
yet though and the so then after that
then we'll find out but it basically has
to do with whatever that method of death
is and there can certainly be civil
suits against the reports it's